e io menti ma tu sei una merda come
cazzo è innanzitutto stai molto
tranquilla io ho mentito bravo traditore
ciao ragazzi benvenuti ad una puntata di
vita buttata oggi mi farò una
chiacchiera con la mia amica camilla
ciao a tutti ma dove devono dare e
telecamere allora quelle la tua queste
la mia creatura dedicata a quella lì la
nostra ok è quella che può essere la tua
signor bossi la tua certo certi voglio
parlare comunque il pubblico posso anche
fare così e tutto quanto ovviamente
ragazzi da casa lo dico analcolico ti
faccio un gin tonic con un gene tonico
oggi ho chiesto consigli d'amore c'è
quella roba un pochino legata agli ex
stran di roba così perché comunque tu
oltre a essere comunque che vi è il
compagna e amica e anche un po esponente
della moda quadrilatero al centro ci
sono io però allo stesso tempo col fatto
che se scatta il secondo libro a due
passi da noi e che si può fare come
spoiler giusti castorani questi due
amici che quella che si innamora e
niente e poi dopo lui muore però della
prima persona da una mano a mescolare lo
saremo
[Musica]
a troppo strano versare del gin tonic in
una tazza da tè comunque gin tonic ad
alcune sì analcolico ma che dite questa
farsa alla tua alla nostra e adesso
possiamo partire con vita buttata
[Musica]
mi piace perché questa mi sponda alla
quarta parete ciao sono quelle della
provincia di bolzano perché questi
uomini praticamente stabili med anni a
donne con cui magari fanno sesso una
volta a settimana
donne che non glielo perdono in un
vedono l'ora di trovare una e sia
spudorata che facesse voglio fare sesso
tutti i giorni e glielo perdendo quando
vogliono loro poi la trovano si stancano
o comunque dopo diventa tutto troppo se
mi spiegate perchè siete così io sono
sincero a me e tutti i giorni ma non per
caso cioè voglio dire secondo me come
tutte le cose sono belle se centellinate
mi verrebbe da dire il troppo stroppia e
tutte le cose to immaginate una
relazione di sei anni dove tu timbri il
cartellino tutte le mattine se poi
esiste qualcuno che dopo sei anni di
relazione comunque toma tutti i giorni a
parte che sacco qui tu non hai capito la
domanda perché lei l'amante
kenya ma in che senso ma non abbiano la
maglietta questa è una fantasia perché
ci sono degli uomini che stanno con
donne con le quali lo fanno una sola
volta a settimana fa cenno dietrologia
la e poi cercano quelle che glielo
prendono che è innanzitutto stai molto
tranquilla io sanitario che adesso non
sto qua c'e ordinaria
mentre nella meta
non ci credo ragazzi che facciamo li
facciamo con cloro calcio no no è bravo
ciò vogliamo già ospite claudio
volta che la mia prima ragazza mi lasciò
ur e innamorato follemente quando mi
lascio mi confessò di aver baciato
un'altra persona e quindi così in
lacrime e le chiesi più volte se insomma
oltre al bacio e se fossi stato altro
lei mi disse che non c'era stato
null'altro e io la ringrazio e che dire
fu lettini follettina chi non ci è
passato dai anch'io mi sono trovata ad
essere
la fidanzata non mi piace la stessa
domanda e gli aumenti dorate
disposizione pianisti che c'era stato un
bacio io in realtà ho già affrontato
queste risorse
[Musica]
rivediamo un attimo un rvm n
sì se tu dici si vuol dire che non hai
mai tradito
bravo traditore può essere personaggio
scegliere di seguire anche allora da
domani la puntata lo condurrà bio grande
guidarono regata sono state tragiche
amal con una piccola rivincita finale
perché non c'è quattro anni di relazione
con la mia extra di cui uno di
convivenza è però dopo una settimana
averla portata a casa dei miei decide di
mettere le corna lasciarmi malissimo
adesso a distanza di sette mesi vi
scrive che mentre a letto con quella lì
pensa a me e questo lo aiuta a venire io
l'ho fatto ma tu sei una merda ho
ripensato a degli ex o persone con le
quali c'era una fortissima intesa
sessuale per tu hai pensato queste
persone in quella determinata
circostanza ma questo non significa che
vuoi tornare col tuo ex
ma anziché forse la diciamo ciò che ti
viene legato a
capite non l'amore quel determinato
pensiero che ti coadiuva la lo sparo
secondo te per fare tipo le uscite sono
qui qui e qui in realtà hanno preso un
italiano
non mi devi assolutamente
fare ok gugliemo scilla e due persone
diverse quando è qui con camilla dovesse
pensare al sesso direbbe oddio che
orrore
e quando invece è sotto un ponte a farsi
sbattere come se fosse l'ultimo giorno
sulla terra penso tutti cioè nessuno e
mai a farlo serve però io nello rega
milla bony ottobre ok e dall'altro
al comando cioè non è che possiamo
umbria carcere quattro zampe si sono
ubriacati alle 10 di mattina ma il
giorno prima che poi sono venuti ad
amazon o uno dei tour ha visto male
salute appunto praticamente dal primo
appuntamento con questo ragazzo della
sera per tutto un certo punto la serata
dice oggi vi faccio un giro in macchina
o poco ci fermiamo e cominciamo a
parlare dopo poco il coach anche a
baciarci nel mentre decide così di
spingere bene a bocca lasciato mela
masticare o quel momento abbastanza
schifata dall'accusa di blocco e l'ha
saputo fuori tutta sincerità gli dico mi
farò anche abbastanza schifo comincia
facciamo tutto il resto poco si blocca
gli dice ti amo
con questo ragazzo non c'era più sentita
che dopo nemmeno un anno è sposato
partiamo dall'inizio io leccato certi
buccini questi c'erano
fate la vicina san marco si aspetta se
io avessi un bolo alimentare trova sassi
che un errore profetici lo schifo è solo
culturale ma non batterico è una è un
pensiero
brava la tua è
un preconcetto tutte le scelte di tacco
ti amo ti amo eccoli ma è un attimo la
storia passata soltanto livello tu pensi
che lui l'abbia detto per recuperare la
questione gomma o erano piani clienti
insperato per te lo presupposto che
questo qui aveva un bisogno di affetto
enorme e ti amo è un qualcosa che può
esempio solo dire sulla conoscenza tu
puoi amare ciò che conosci e tu non
conoscerai mai una persona davvero
quindi tu non potrai mai amare veramente
qualcuno se non te stesso che è la forma
più alta da d'amore
[Musica]
per dare dei consigli che ti spiego è
partita bisogna saper ascoltare tu sei
una che va oltre le parole questa è
comunque una cosa che dice lui e pochi
altri quindi non vi fidate camilla la
capacità di parlarti aspetta altro per
fare l'esperimento allora
io tendo nelle situazioni dove sono
molto concentrata quindi è una cosa
positiva cioè se io stupendo con te io
faccio questo vuol dire che sono molto
attento a quello che sta dicendo se io
invece non lo facciamo la mente sto
pensando a te perché cosa che fai tu lo
ripeti e poi uno minuti dice sia questo
tipo merito un omino che dica così come
di lamiere black comunque matrix
qui analcolico voglio provare quando
proverà a sfidare la campionessa rg ha
ripreso momento dice se voglio sfidare
la campionessa perché poi lo mandiamo
ogni volta che io non ne prendo una
troviamo delle tasse la banda ok io sono
l'uomo sessuale a sessuale bello e sono
affetti e lo staff schizzi una bimba
come una biscia no sto cercando di
capire anche al significato logico che
non c'è
ma sta urlando
schizzi
[Risate]
ciao
spiriti momenti
schizzi come una biscia piedini come una
biscia poteva
sentiamo paese che
si p si
[Musica]
no
zitti schizzi pizzi finti schizzi
[Musica]
ma grandi
capacità e la salsa barbecue la senza
armatura della maionese
la
larghi no no è troppo lunga io vedo
questo
la la ce l'abbiamo
salsa barbecue
sì ma come cazzo balli
sardi minimo sei capace e meglio è
meglio
della maionese era che cazzo
[Musica]
io voglio reggio è infinito
io parlerò così ok perfetto perfetto per
me
come potete dire ma cesar da solo seria
romizi travel agents
bravissima mi piacciono mi piacciono i
letti caccia alla caccia e lampone mi
piacciono i ghiaccioli giocatore
che ti piacciono lecca lecca
lecca lampone e quando si parla di
impresa dice sul fuoco
di cesena una quercia indietro
è un callo sul collo che brilla un gatto
sul collo che pilla
a un calo sul collo che brilla ma che
cazzo vuol dire è un pazzo scrive luca
giurato [ __ ]
prova a spegnere prova a spegnere e
riaccendere l'accendere no e riapprova
spenderla accenderà prova a spegnere e
riaccendere e prova a spegnere e
riaccendere l'incendio hashtag passa
a sta a casa
astag a chuck
costante atac
da dire bene le parole no no no non è
vero se ti parlo così mi capisci
capitoli la serravalle così tu non senti
no così però così capisci quello che
quindi parlo bene se astag casa i
tag ac dare
haters ed
hi tech
akers e
non è tipo ciao ei no no no no una
parola inizia è giusto questo sito e ea
terra
ma che cazzo di parola è iper ma dovrei
già capirla questa parola da hayden
terzo basta mediatori laser
la parola
passa tutta lo
fa iniziando la canzone non mi capisce
se parlo così ma così non ti sento
si chiama stiamo fi
si chiama si chiama cornetto non brioche
cornetto non breve o solo
se poi e tenera
io nella nella carbonara carbonara ci
metto che sarà 11 volte la brava
imbecille non ci vanno un po un poco di
panna ce la metto ce la metto si matura
e dai oltre il normale perché la banale
questo è questo i tuoi autori è autori
giocavo
carbonatica tornano indietro da te dare
il pane il pane al cane pazzo è
l'antipasto è una pratica è un prete
capitale all
l allarme cane pazzo date il calcio al
pazzo che batte il padre pane al pane
e bravo
attuale duravano abeti rossa mi sa che
qui ha spaccato tanto brava tentava di
far emilio scoprirà invece a breve che
hai un'altra voce e un altro cento
quando hai le cuffie voce alta
che schifo c'è un cappello leva melo non
arriva nessuno ha
contattato
il mio
più ghiaccio vado mai avuto un cazzo e
sto così secondo te normalmente scusami
e tutto
mi ha contaminato anche qui ma con il
capello rende effettivamente era proprio
dalla madre che le basse temperature lo
sai che uccidono i batteri non per i
[ __ ]
praticamente la prima volta che sono
uscita con il mio compagno siamo andati
in toscana perché lui era ancora
fidanzato ed io non lo sapevo avevo
tantissima aia nella pancia non potevo
fare una propria moto stava cercando il
ristorante lui impatto state altro paese
in toscana nessuno aveva bloccato il
ristorante la terza persona che non
sapeva dargli indicazioni ios botto
arrivi
ms1
scoreggione enorme non sono più riuscita
prima
di una di merda atroce cioè
adesso vediamo però non si di queste
cose quando c'è chiara nella pancia è
brutto e morta una cantante per la pace
è finito all'ospedale la news
è molto brutto e e capitan distrutto il
giornale
perché si sa tenere un peso
e qualche anno fa frequentava una
ragazza era piuttosto strano a volte
spariva per diversi giorni è la cosa mi
ha reso molto sospettoso un giorno per
cui la coincidenza grob in un'aula
studio un ragazzo è un certo punto
parlando del piede in meno stavamo
parlando di ragazze faceva descrizione
lista ragazza che frequentava e lui
abbastanza sorpreso mi chiese come si
chiamasse ricordo che nel momento in cui
ci chiese di vedere il suo profilo e
glielo mostrare la sua espressione
cambiò drasticamente e mi disse che era
la sua fidanzata
scopriamo insieme che lei lei avevano un
terzo ragazzo al che noi tutti e tre ci
siamo incontrati ci siamo fatto in sé
seconda di quando amo questo selphy
tutto quello che aveva legano a
rispondere era bella capisce questa è
una storia molto delicata questa
triangolazione a me non piace voglio
parlare onestamente
c'è stato un periodo dove triangolato la
figura geometrica aveva molti lati non
decadono
a interrogarci su gli angoli e un lavoro
a tempo pieno di frequentazione e
soprattutto anche deve avere una certa
prestanza fisica per prima cosa cazzi
tuoi ti dico questo farò mykonos e le
persone all'interno di questa figura
geometrica chiamiamola così sono
coscienti consapevoli e concordi allora
guarda io ti faccio che faccio una sfera
pubblica l'altro è questa liberazione
non mi sono consapevoli e tu sei l'unico
stronzo tu sei il goniometro
in basso di questa figura geometrica e
allora mi 61 e lei palese è un compasso
era chiaro che fossero frequentazione ma
chi ha esordito dicendo lei parlo di me
quindi tanase rispetto parola fascia di
rispetto dell'ordine non hanno rispetto
cioè come sto dicendo io frequentavo e
quindi mi sono divertito e magari
fermentato per un mese due mesetti prima
dire mi alzo da questo tavolo anche
perché lo so più se per me lei aveva
messo le basi in tre scarpe come cazzo
fai come fai ma è un lavoro a tempo
pieno durante obbligato è però sai che
lo potrebbe fare cecilia questa puntata
ragazzi è un cerchio che si chiude
noi siamo partiti dalla giuria che
voleva per la mattina voleva prenderlo e
non solo ogni giorno e si chiedeva
perché non esistono uomini in grado di
soddisfare l'abbiamo data
migliaia che le ha prima notte l'abbiamo
data risposta ma noi lasciamo cadere
d'arte ma queste camere
dell'amore alla fine di questa puntata
per darti una risposta è la risposta è
questa clelia devi essere una forma
geometrica si l'esagono che
classi l'esagono che la sono metria
cavaliera che si era immaginata potrebbe
racchiudere parole sagge
righe 0 i viola
mi sono dimenticato perché volevo dire
una cosa tornando a questa storia e alla
paura claudia questa storia aveva un
inizio e la clinica
sì la griglia è che puoi arrivare le
note indirizzate
cavill devo dire che sono arrivati alla
fine di questa puntata ok io ti
ringrazio di cuore se ti messa proprio a
nudo ea servizio soprattutto di quelli
che sono stati poi tutti quanti messaggi
che ci sono arrivati grazie ragazzi
erano eterno per averci demandati se
volete delle domande alle quali poi non
ricevere risposte perché camilla non
darà altre risposte siete qua sotto
risponderò io ho detto ciao ragazzi noi
ci vediamo sempre qui marzo quando un
altro ospite
mafia brillando che è bravissimo
[Musica]